Josh: Balance in video games is always a contentious issue and players are quick
to voice their opinions on any changes
developers make especially when it
affects them personally. When something
is made weaker in a video game we call
it a "nerf", but where did that expression
come from and why has the term gained
such massive popularity? To find out we
have to travel back in time to 1997.
The easiest just got easier.
Instant messages.
I can customize my e-mail.
My niece sent me a picture.
If you have a phone line, you can be online.
It's the easiest way to keep up with old
friends.
Everyone I know is on it.
Josh: It's hard to overstate how
different the internet was back then.
About 37% of American households had
home computers and only 18 percent of
them had internet access.
Along with the first cloned sheep,
Starfox 64, and 56k
modems, 1997 saw the release of
Ultima Online, a massively multiplayer online role-playing game or MMORPG.
It was a new breed of game,
one that offered possibilities unlike its predecessors
and because of the persistent world, it
also had to adapt to its players.
Richard Garriott: It was very broken upon launch and
one of the first things is we're here
scrambling to get to catch-up with stuff
we realized that people are both really
upset and really passionate about being there.
You know, if they were
upset enough they could just quit and go
away and go somewhere else.
But these people weren't quitting and going away.
They cared. They cared, they were in the game
protesting in the game.
At one point in Ultima Online, swords were toned down
be a little less effective.
The response from some players was that they felt
like Nerf weapons instead of actual
blades.
The term "nerf" soon became
shorthand for anything that was rendered
less effective due to a game update and
it makes a lot of sense.
It's easier to say it was "nerfed" instead of saying
"Balance changes made my character
weaker," or something like that.
But it's easy to forget that there was a time when nerfs
were a lot more difficult to implement.
Titles like Street Fighter 3
which had long-lived competitive scenes
had to release completely new versions
of the game to change anything.
Even so, the last version of the game Third Strike had two extremely overpowered
characters in Ken and Chun-Li.
Had Capcom been able to patch the game, would we
have seen the ever iconic EVO Moment 37?
Ken and Chun-Li would have been obvious
targets for nerfs, so who knows?
Today the Internet
has made patching games easier than ever.
That means games can be updated more
frequently, but it also means that nerfs
are inescapable.
Jay: Well, f**k that!
The fact that balance changes are not always
explained and that developers often have
differing views of the game's balance
than players has also led to the term's
development as a meme.
In early League of Legends,
the champion Irelia was nerfed over and over.
While other champions
perceived as stronger
weren't changed as quickly.
This gave rise to the meme,
"Better Nerf Irelia", a sarcastic response
to basically anything.
Implying that Riot would nerf the champion for
illogical reasons,
or even no reason at all.
Rather than nerfing the champions that needed it.
Sometimes though memes don't
represent reality.
Though Better Nerf Irelia stuck around,
the champion didn't
actually suffer that many nerfs after
the early years of LoL – a fact that TSM's
TheOddOne discovered on stream.
TheOddOne: You always nerf us!
When was the last time Irelia has even been nerfed?
I'm gonna look it up.
Let's go look it up right now...
What?
What?!
She wasn't even f**king – hasn't even
been f**king nerfed!
Holy shit. Irelia players are geniuses.
Like, she doesn't even get f**kin' nerfed.
It's all been buffs...
Some game developers like Blizzard Entertainment
haven't shied away from community
sensitivity around character balancing.
In Overwatch, they've even gone as far
as acknowledging it in game
with self-referential humor.
I reached out to Hasbro to find out how they felt about
the Nerf trademark being used to
describe things that were made worse.
Unsurprisingly, they didn't respond.
Although, I did find a Nerf dart
in my driveway the other day.
So there you have it.
Nerfs – now an inescapable fact of gaming life.
Here's to hoping none are
headed your way
– unless you're a Jayce player...
...in which case,
f**k you.
[sigh]
Okay. How was that?
???: Pretty good, but...
[Nerf gun being loaded]
Hasbro send their regards.
Announcer: You got Nerfed!
Miles: Do you want to see it?
Nav: I have eyedrops...
[Josh laughs]
Josh: Do I want to see it?! Yes, I want to see it!
Nav: Once his vision comes back he'll see it.
[laughter]
It really hurt!
Nav: Are you okay?
Josh: Yeah, I'm fine...